movie decides that needs some sort of
flash-forward opening to a spot roughly
fourteen minutes later in the film I've
heard stories of earth said Jaden Smith
not knowing the microphones were on also
Jaden Smith narration a paradise until
we destroyed it humans are terrible just
terrible and they destroyed the earth
cliche are these people boarding a
rocket this is the thing that usually
detaches from the aircraft when it goes
into space right
Nova Pan named after the Greek
predecessor of Sentinel Prime's thank
God for that ranger image archive or we
wouldn't have had these important images
and establishing shots
the aliens released to us monsters bred
to kill humans sudden aliens and they
sick monsters on us did the aliens do
also so the aliens just took several
years off to breed perfect human killing
animals it takes decades just to get the
miniature Pomeranians perfectly
miniature and Pomeranian monsters ready
to kill humans wait a fucking minute how
did the aliens even know the humans were
coming there's a lot of backstory here
that would probably make for a far more
interesting movie but no one is
interested in telling it technically
blind Ursa sees aliens breed perfect
human killing machine that cannot
concede looks like who bill went too far
this Christmas also how the ever-loving
did the blind ass Ursa managed to
arrange the dead human bodies on the
tree like Christmas ornaments huh
someone sketched a cool storyboard
everyone liked and no one had the heart
to explain to M night that the actual
shot had no logic whatsoever in it also
I know cypher doesn't show fear but does
he have to use a close-range weapon to
kill the Ursa and why don't they get
everybody else the hell out of there
while cypher spins 360 degrees with two
guns blasting the shit outta monsters
this movie starts with a flash-forward
that comes to a flash back then back to
the forward only to then back up a bit
and start the actual fucking story sadly
future new earth still includes running
oh my god he's the main character in
this movie isn't he we're gonna have to
put up with this aren't we okay hold up
how long have humans been on this planet
as soon as they got here aliens attacked
them but they had time to build these
elaborate houses and is that a huge city
I see in the background every frame of
this movie creates more questions than
it answers how did a guy as socially
awkward as this movie presents him to be
ever establish contact with this woman
let alone a relationship our finals when
you came back home it was daytime you're
just now asking him this question Will
Smith is a dick to the human that came
from his dick it's not an official movie
set in the future without hologram
I see the hammock has replaced the bed
in the future I don't like this take it
easy this is rusty should you really be
talking to your preteen son about your
sex life
well someone saw Star Wars oh wow movie
that came out good and well after John
Carter also cribs a little from John
Carter and thinks I won't notice but I
did the features loan innovation to
today's iPad is to make it fluffy the
other thing about Holograms is that
everybody can get up in your bidness and
we're seriously as a species going to
reject full-color graphics on our
devices in the future we're going back
to the graphics of the vic-20 computer
I'm gonna play lunar lander again the
fuck
floppy iPad burrito conveniently
everyone falls asleep except for Jaden
so he can sneak off to explore the ship
room with dangerous din it is easily
accessible also room with dangerous in
it has a wall that is made of wheat for
some reason
hey can you lock also people out of
nowhere are in this section of the ship
and we're apparently making no noise
whatsoever when kit came back here oh
good here comes the all-important
flashback told to us in a foggy
fragments it's really more interesting
that way no it is a ciphers wedding band
can detect trouble with the ship
apparently the Ursa can only detect
human fear at a distance of 10 feet but
why the Ursa is in a cage where is he
standing right now how did he get in
here is there a special commander's
entrance into the Ursus storage room
what's the last known position of the
closest asteroid star this guy's so good
he can fucking sense asteroid storms so
why is there any tension in this movie
at all
a detected graviton vibrations in the
hall but she detected how it's my
wedding band of course mass expansion is
one in a million then explain the
graviton build-up asshole
how often are you my wife would give a
very interesting answer to that question
uh-huh those wives but you have an
answer to that question these dicks
should be dead
forget about one of these hitting them
shouldn't a whole bunch of asteroids be
hitting them I mean did they find a
clear roadway in a surprising asteroid
field
this planet husband declared unfit for
human habitation you need to press the
red light before the computer will tell
you that this is one of those things
where you swear they added it so that
Will Smith could show how amazingly
smartest character is herpes oh by the
way this is your old homeland earth not
important to the discussion just don't
land there set it down
but please do so in a way that leaves
everyone on this ship dead except for me
my son and the deadly human killing
earth supplies we don't heavy damage
from an asteroid storm and I'm going
down with bingo power if this term bingo
power is being used correctly that means
they have enough power to get back to
the police they intended the land but in
this context it doesn't sound like that
at all that sounds like someone said
it'd be cool if we had the pilots a
bingo power let's do that back to where
this movie started during the opening
credits we sure needed that quick
glimpse into the scene or else I would
have already left the theater by now
thank God he was strapped in or else he
might not have survived that crash from
tens of thousands of feet like his dad
did
hey let's save a little money here just
by cutting the black you sure that's not
a cop-out yeah who cares
yep definitely should take off the
oxygen mask after crash-landing on an
alien planet
you're positive there's breathable air
so what's the harm right see that's
great but didn't we already see plenty
of hole punches down the rest of the
ship's hallway how does closing this one
thing let you breathe normally okay so
cipher was getting sucked out of the
ship by something it's not like whatever
sucks you out of a ship stops doing it
once you get out of you plus the ship
went through numerous other calamities
after this so come on he's dead already
Rangers come off ranges Connor yep only
the Smith's survived this crash this
still works as we find out earth is
sustaining life pretty well full of
trees and wildlife
maybe it's an evolution everything but
seems like there's plenty of oxygen and
it doesn't make any sense why he needs
the miles laughs a backpack equipped
with digital and virtual imaging so I
will be able to see everything that you
see and what you do not see well that
sounds like insanely convenient bull to
me you have like little cameras that
somehow broadcast a signal back to the
ship or someone can watch it on some
sort of TV look for this ship was just
transporting a bunch of people do a
training mission right so they thought
of giving everyone incredibly useful
suits like this but not have more homing
beacons everything on this planet has
evolved to kill humans but why this is
earth didn't you assholes leave like
long enough ago that there aren't any
buildings or any
a science here of former human life when
this planet's inhabitants have evolved
since then to kill something else is
this the stupidest line in 2013 film
history this is Earth does he just think
about this constantly no matter what is
said to him there are three
possibilities the first and most likely
is that it died in the crash like we did
what happened exactly my question how do
you have digital and thermal imaging and
not see what happened everything on this
planet has evolved to kill humans except
those burgers you see back there
initiating remote probe recon primary
target Ursa you couldn't do this earlier
before your kid went out into the
wilderness most of the planet freezes
over completely at night that's why
there's such amazingly lush vegetation
and wildlife everywhere geez every
useful thing except the beacon survived
this craft it's Moby Dick he said I
could even hold on to it hold on what
yeah this isn't the pronoun game here
man
she 100% meant the book I know the book
is called Moby Dick but damn do you
think your daughter would really tell
you that the guy had met his penis did
they really kill these whales Christ
here we go in the absence of humans
earth has turned into Endor your suit is
made of smart fabric it has motion
sensors have smart fabric are you
fucking serious and what good is it if
you don't personally know where the
danger is and you have to rely on
somebody reading your thermal and
digital imaging to tell you where it's
coming from
also this so-called smart fabric didn't
do anything earlier when the tarantula
ran across his hand or when he saw those
Buffalo and Birds you're telling me the
suit can detect threats attracting a
life-form moving toward you from the
West
okay so despite knowing the direction
the thing is coming from katana
continues looking around in circles I
know he didn't make Ranger but geez does
he know nothing about orienteering these
monkey things are right on top of them
but somehow he gets a 50-yard head start
into the next shot there was literally
nothing he could do that would allow
these monkeys to catch up to him monkeys
have the same weakness as the aliens in
science and I could almost make a bonus
round of all the things Will Smith says
that his son ignores in this movie suit
changes back to normal just now after
the dangerous long past the hit see the
question is why can't cypher tell him
where to direct his hands you know these
cameras are both convenient and
inconvenient depending on what the story
means plants from The Happening continue
to for the earth long after we're gone
um who is camera self surgery look a bit
I like the idea of a scene where zoe
kravitz says something to Will Smith
continue the words blow
dad and come on but this isn't how I
would have written it these things are
in a pretty safe pouch he didn't crash
into anything so how are their damaged
oxygen things in here computer suddenly
beeps loudly because of a couple extra
heartbeats per minute also
wait a minute his heart rate went up a
couple of beats per minute mother is
lying to me about the oxygen vials isn't
he also why does he feel the need to lie
about this it's not like he did anything
to destroy those vials also cipher can
see everything except for this little
deception remember earlier when he was
asking his son to blink his eyes and he
could see his son's eyes while doing so
I didn't you guys are expecting a
Cinerama here with this thing but
honestly this movie is mostly just
boring really abort mission
okay Q you put your kid out in this
horribly dangerous world where anything
can kill him
and now you want him to come back
because you don't think he can make the
jump and what's the plan after that well
I guess we'll die anyway also his kit
once followed your orders during this
entire mission come on man excuse to
have a father-son argument is excuse
don't come at flashback about sister's
horrible ursa death continues to pad the
film's link to tell you've got incoming
yeah but his suit didn't change so it's
probably not a threat it wakes up just
in time to defend himself during a
random jungle cat attack on an eagle
nest katana has feelings for the
children of the giant eagle that plans
to eat him movie rips off the X Mach and
a giant Eagles from Lord of the Rings
don't know what it is about this scene
that's so weird maybe it's because it
looks fake eesh
nice of the Ursa to scream right when
the general discovered this shot of the
dead fellow soldiers also I'm trying to
figure out how an Ursa does this this is
super high up in the trees we haven't
heard anything about these monsters
flying or climbing abilities hey how
come the motion sensing suits didn't
turn black with the motion of these
fucking wild pigs over here asshole
idiot kid who doesn't know what
direction East is somehow can build a
raft from scratch in 15 minutes
hallucination ex machina also when you
loosen eight your dead sister make sure
she looks sexy as hell goodness be a
hallucination also forgiveness from
beyond the grave is a handy thing for
this kid to have considering how haunted
he is by letting his sister die why can
you ghosts
well she's ghosting right now even Jaden
Smith's hallucinations are getting tired
of his bull oh hey the suit changes
color when it gets cold too how cool the
feature is that since human beings are
unable to sense temperature without
visual cues from their clothing not to
be outdone and night shyamalan goes the
Tolkien / Peter Jackson route and Aquila
ex machina zatia into overdrive
everything on this planet has evolved to
kill humans except a handful that have
evolved to protect humans that is
atmosphere is in hazardous anymore now
that you have hope so wait there's a
beacon that can shoot all the way across
space and it gets sidetracked by signal
interference but who is camera position
status
beacon it's not firing yeah because
space doesn't contain anything that can
interfere with signals what use is a
beacon like this if it gets jammed by
the Earth's atmosphere it has found you
yet once again kits suit does not change
movie steals the alien is directly in
the general vicinity of the hero but
alien is nowhere to be found thing from
aliens he survives this cave tumbled by
the way while we watch this versa attack
kit I think it's an important question
as to why it doesn't need any special
oxygen vials or anything to live on this
planet
he survives this movie claims that the
Ursa has its leg stuck in the hole and
movie is lying to me okay it won't be
able to smell you the Ursa is attacking
them in their home which continues the
weird question this movie has yet to
answer why did the aliens who bred and
unleash the Ursa allow these settlements
to be built up in the first place why
didn't they blow these things up they
just unleash these monsters everywhere
and I guess then they pieced out to some
other planet while the Ursa took care of
the humans how does cat I eventually
learned a ghost he remembers his sister
dying which he's only done in this movie
about 12 times already just now kid is
having a flashback to a hallucination
elevado Ursa is this super fearsome
killing thing but without the smell of
fear it apparently literally has zero
other senses Jaden Smith is Ghost Dog
apparently beacons are literal beams of
light that shoot into the atmosphere
this seriously couldn't beat the ionic
layer a minute ago slow-motion medical
attention also this might be the most
doctors per human being in the history
of Medicine none of these doctors purple
suits are turning black at the movement
of other nearby humans Seifer tries to
one-up the one-legged guy from earlier
in the movie Moby Dick reference pays
off somehow that mean that much to this
story but sure whales this planet has
evolved to kill humans
you
is it alien planet is there air you know
you're going to retrieve that beacon or
we are going to die we follow orders or
people die it's that simple
are we clear do you know where we are no
sir
welcome to earth and I see your Sports
is as big as mine
[Music]
turn around and give her the shot come
on okay look while I'm doing this you
take off your shirt and
[Music]
normally I'd be here to warn you about
an ad but this time I'm here to warn you
about a book actually I'm not even
really warning you very well since I
didn't start talking until after the
image was already on screen and now I'm
already out of time